discipline equals Freedom episode one
Joo willink here with Eko
Charles
why why why am I feeling compelled to
talk about this well as I go through
life I have often said and I've been
saying for a long time that discipline
is what you need in your life and what I
often times think people
Miss is the same thing they miss about
leadership which is that leadership is a
skill and a lot of people think
leadership is natural right you look at
a person and you see them and their
leadership position and they're
confident and they got Charisma and
they're making decisions and it's very
easy to think that all of
that is just natural gift now listen
some of it was natural gift right some
you're going to have some level of
natural gift you're really charismatic
you're very articulate and that's a
skill MH that you were born with some of
it but then over time you become more
articulate can you can you become more
charismatic do you think you can become
more charismatic yes yes you can
absolutely I've watched people become
more charismatic as time goes by
generally speaking often times has to do
with their confidence level what breeds
confidence well it's when they practice
when they rehearse when they acquire
skills when they become more capable the
more capable you are the more confident
you are you ever seen a kid going into a
wrestling match or a Jiu-Jitsu match and
they're really good
mhm they're confident why are they
confident they're confident because
they've been training their ass off for
a long period of time any sport you
watch anybody going into any sport if
they train really hard Tom Brady playing
football right you'd see him going on
the field he didn't look nervous why
because that guy was just training all
time Michael Jordan why does Michael
Jordan want the ball in the clutch
moment cuz he practiced Larry Bird why
why does he want the ball when there's
two seconds left on the clock and they
they're taking the ball in bounds why
does he want the ball cuz he's practiced
and he's confident and that is seems
like Charisma and it probably is
charisma so so leadership is not
something oh you're just born with and
like I said there are aspects of it that
you have some level of a gift but then
you get better at it and the more you
stand up and talk to people the more you
put out word the more you get put into
situations where you have to make
decisions the better you get at those
things as long as you're humble enough
to correct yourself and admit oh that
wasn't a good decision as long as you
can do that but so we we understand and
I've been saying this at ashon front for
a while leadership is a skill I wrote it
in leadership strategy and tactics
leadership is a skill you can learn it
well it's the same thing with discipline
it's the same thing with discipline you
can learn the skill
of of discipline and can you be born
with some of it yep you can get some
people that are born and and look is it
nature or nurture I'm not 100% sure but
there's some combination of that that
you can you can grow up and be a more
disciplined person than someone else
right if you look at the the Big Five on
the psychology chart and you're a very
conscientious person that person
generally speaking is going to be more
disciplined
human but regardless of where you are on
that chart you can become more
disciplined there's no doubt about
it and and for
me you know Echo Charles on one of our
earliest podcasts you said something
along the lines of there's nothing that
will affect and help your life more in
more different aspects of your life than
exercise right so when we're waking up
or when we're working out I was going to
say when we wake up and work out but I
know not everyone's in that category but
when we work
out everything gets better everything
gets better every aspect of your life
gets better your relationships get
better your business gets better your
mental health gets better your attitude
gets everything gets better just from
exercise just from
exercise
well I actually would say that we could
take
that one step to the left one precursor
the precursor to exercise that would be
an even more impactful thing in every
aspect of your life would be discipline
I I think it's the most
important characteristic the most
important aspect of your life as a human
being is to be disciplined and again
this is why I wrote the book discipline
equals freedom field
manual now what made me start thinking
about this when did I learn about it
what made me pay attention to this well
if I'm going to go if I'm going to go
old
school old black F Black Flag album
Henry Rollins it's a live
album and in the song My War which is
like basically I'm against you know it's
my War it's against I'm I'm against
everybody but at one point it's a live
album and I'm a little kid listening to
this I'm probably 13 13-year-old kid MH
and I hear
Rollins and at one point during the
song he's saying the discipline I am the
discipline I don't even know what this
word means at the time I'm 13 years old
right so you know you kind of start to
figure it out I I don't know if I looked
it up in the dictionary I don't know if
I had that kind of I had that kind of
kind of wherewithal to go to the library
and pull out a dictionary but you know
you had some indication so at young age
I what does it mean why is this guy
talking about the
discipline I am the discipline what does
that mean but as a young kid again when
you're looking at when I was looking at
Henry Rollins when I was 13 years old
he's a 23y old guy seems like a tough
guy right seems
strong okay those were things that I
looked at and said those things are good
good to be strong seems like a good
thing to be strong when when when all
the punk rockers back in the day were
you know doing drugs or whatever and he
was working out you'd see him doing
push-ups so he's trying to be strong all
these other people are doing other that
seems like the good thing that must be
the discipline that's it so that's what
I need right so that's probably that is
no doubt my probably the first little
kernel in my brain of discipline and so
then I started saying okay what does
that mean so I need to work out I need
to do push-ups I need to do pull-ups
that's what I need to do and I had this
goal of course of going into the
military going into the SEAL Teams
becoming some kind of a Commando so
discipline seemed like the thing I
needed that the thing I needed so I did
worked out got ready left go to the SEAL
Teams go through SEAL training and
and the thing about SEAL
training does it teach you
discipline
kind of the thing about SEAL training
and the thing about all military
training all basic military training
which which basic SEAL training this
basic underwater demolition SEAL
training that's buds basic underwater
demolition
seal it's basic so what you're getting
is imposed discipline it is imposed
discipline it's like you are going to go
do push-ups you are now going to carry
this log you are now going to do this
you're now going to do something you're
now going to sit in the water until we
tell you get out of the water that's
what it's about so it's imposed
discipline it's imposed discipline it's
not it's not you're not they're not
sitting you down and and explaining to
you the value of discipline you're not
hearing that I didn't hear it I don't
think I heard the word discipline one
time when I was going through basic SEAL
training I don't think I heard that word
one time I probably had a little kernel
of it in my
head what you do
learn you what you start to see and what
you have to have is you have to have
some level of
self-discipline you have to have some
level of self-discipline
because if
you're going through SEAL training and
you didn't have the discipline to
run to get prepared you're not going to
make it if you didn't have the
discipline to do pull-ups you're not
going to be able to climb those ropes
and you're not going to make it so
there's a bunch of reasons
why it it ends up
surfacing and it ends up becoming if
you're if you if you're aware of it it
ends up becoming something that you see
as very valuable because you see people
that are undisciplined they only do what
they're forced to
do that's not going to
be that's that's not the best
route if you're only doing what you're
forced to do that's not that's not what
we're looking for that's not what the
SEAL Teams is looking for look they do
it and there's if you don't do what
you're forced to you don't make it
obviously you it's called quitting we
force you to put boat on your head and
run 10 miles you don't want to do that
anymore cool you
quit but what we really want is someone
that's going to discover
[Music]
self-discipline and what that means is
that means that you
are you are the general and you are also
the soldier you're the one that's making
you do the task right so if I'm the
general and Echoes the soldier I'm like
this is what you have to do and you do
it cool that's imposed
discipline that's actually not that
hard but for me to be the general and me
to be the soldier that's harder that's
in fact this is why people have um uh uh
personal trainers right they know what
they have to do but they need someone to
they actually need someone to tell them
what to do like do one more rep they
know what to look I give you the workout
program here it is go do it but they
need someone actually there to impose
discipline on them otherwise they're not
going to do
it strange right it's real it's real
it's
real
so we have to realize that we are the
ones that are imposing discipline and we
are the ones that are executing we're
the general and we're the soldier so
think about that get yourself in the
mindset that yes I'm the general and yes
I'm the soldier and I've got to be good
at both
I've got to be good at setting out what
it is I need to do and then I need to be
good at doing what I need to do I'm not
allowed to refuse orders by the way I'm
not allowed to have a mutiny there's no
Mutiny allowed when the general says do
it you've got to do it and we miss that
little piece
sometimes sometimes we end up with a a
military unit in our brain that's not
functioning cuz the General's putting
out word and the soldiers not listening
the solders the soldier lacks discipline
the solders making excuses the solders
rationalizing and the general doesn't
know what to
do and so what do you end up with
failure you end up with failure across
the board in multiple
areas so so if you're
lucky going through basic skill training
you can kind of get it you kind of learn
some
self-discipline
and that that's what we need in our
lives that's what we
need that's what having that General in
position having that commanding officer
in position to make decisions for you
the soldier that's what we
need and this is why I wrote about this
in in the discipline equal freedom field
manual I get that you don't want to do
it I get that you don't want to do it I
get that the bed is warm and the pillow
is soft I understand that I get that the
water is
cold I get that you're
tired I get all those
things but if you want to achieve your
goals if you want to move forward if you
want to actually become who it is you
know you can become
there's no easy way of getting there
there's no shortcut there's no
hack there is only
discipline that's
it go into the book right now discipline
equals freedom field manual there must
be
discipline which think about that for 10
seconds of your life there must be
discipline if there's not discipline the
soldiers are doing whatever they
want and guess what the soldiers want to
do they want to sleep they want to get
drunk they want to eat donuts that's
what the soldiers want to
do that's what they want to do they're
looking for immediate
gratification so not allowed there must
be discipline discipline the root of all
good qualities the driver of daily
execution daily
execution daily execution doesn't come
from motivation yeah look if you get
motivated today great great if you're
motivated tomorrow morning and you
watched a cool video you got motivated
good good I'm happy hell yeah but how
many what's the what's the halflife of a
video having an impact on you what's the
halflife how many times can you watch a
video before you say to yourself all
right I get it and it wore
off right what's the halflife so the
daily driver isn't motivation it's not a
video The Daily the the daily driver has
no thoughts almost
whatsoever it only has
discipline it only has discipline did
you ever see the movie
Soldier yes and Kurt Russell Kurt
Russell look in my own Twisted way
that's sort of the life I
wanted right in my own Twisted way
that's kind of the life I wanted but at
one point in that movie you know in the
movie The the guy he's just a soldier
he's he works out he trains when there's
a war they send him to war when there's
no war he sits on his bed and waits for
war and trains yeah that's the fantasy
that many of us have right true so at
one point though he ends up on this
other planet and they're he ends up with
a family living with a normal family and
the mom of this normal family she's
asking him don't you yo don't you do you
have any what do you feel
do you feel anything and his
answer
is
fear and discipline and he says it like
that
fear and discipline which is
really it's really a heavy thing because
the only thing he feels is fear like I'm
afraid I'm going to die I'm afraid I'm
going to fail I'm afraid I'm not going
to do the right thing I'm afraid I'm
going to make a mistake and all that all
all that is overcome by one thing
discipline so when we talk about the
daily driver of execution it's got to be
disciplined this is the core principle
going back to the book The Core
principle that overcomes laziness and
lethargy and excuses discipline defeats
the infinite excuses that say not today
not now I need a rest I will do it
tomorrow and you can just keep going on
the excuse List have we ever sat down we
should get on uh chat GPT and just have
it come up with excuses give me 7,000
excuses why I shouldn't work out today
it'll do it too 7,000 it'll give you
7,000 excuses yeah on why you shouldn't
work out today and you know what
probably 6,000 of them you can kind of
Nod your head and be like well not a bad
one so excuses are a dime a dozen
they're everywhere
we have to have discipline to overcome
them so then going back to the book
what's the hack how do you become
stronger smarter faster healthier how do
you become better how do you achieve
true
Freedom there is only one
way the way of
discipline so that's what we're doing
that is the discipline
and with
that if you want to do some more
discipline activities go to theed defret
decom if you need fuel go to joof
fuel.com if you need gear go to origin
usa.com or Joost store.com and if you
need leadership go to echon front.com
and until next time this is Ekko and Joo
out